os lo podéis imaginar estás en un bar y
sales a una discoteca todo eso y te
puedes hablar que al rato pues sale en
la conversación y tú en qué trabajas
y cómo te piensas que tu trabajo es
interesante desde soy matemático
cuando esa conversación sigue
invariablemente en algún momento aparece
una de estas dos frases a joel que era
fatal con las matemáticas pero no era
culpa mía es que el profesor era
horroroso
y ve pero eso de las matemáticas para
qué sirve me ocuparé del caso b
cuando alguien te pregunta para qué
sirve las matemáticas no te está
preguntando por aplicaciones de las
ciencias matemáticas te está preguntando
y yo porque tuve que estudiar a esa
[ __ ] que no volvía a usar nunca es lo
que le está preguntando realmente
ante esto cuando a un matemático le
preguntan para qué sirven las
matemáticas los matemáticos nos
dividimos en grupos un 54.51 de los
matemáticos tomaba una postura de ataque
y un 44 como 77% de los matemáticos toma
una postura a la defensiva hay un 0-8
raro entre los que me incluyo que son
los del ataque los del ataque son
matemáticos que te dicen que esa
pregunta no tiene sentido porque las
matemáticas tienen un sentido propio si
mismas son un edificio bellísimo que
tiene una lógica propia que se construye
y que no hace falta que uno esté siempre
mirando las posibles aplicaciones para
qué sirve la poesía para qué sirve el
amor para qué sirve la vida misma qué
pregunta es esa
hardy por ejemplo es un exponente de
este de este ataque y los que están a la
defensiva te dicen que aunque no te des
cuenta cariño las matemáticas están
detrás de todo
y esto siempre nombran siempre nombran
los puentes y las computadoras si no
saben matemáticas se te cae el puente
realmente las computadoras son todo
matemáticas ahora este les ha dado
también por decirte que detrás de la
seguridad informática de las tarjetas de
crédito están los números primos
estas son las respuestas que te va a dar
tu profe de matemáticas si le preguntas
es de los de la defensiva
vale pero hay quien lleva razón los que
dicen que las matemáticas no tienen por
qué servir para nada los que dicen que
realmente están detrás de todo realmente
tienen razón los dos pero os he dicho
que yo era de ese 0 8% raro que dice
otra cosa verdad así que dale
preguntarse para qué sirve las
matemáticas
vale un 76 34 de la gente ha preguntado
hay un 23 con 41 que se ha callado y 108
que yo no sé lo que están haciendo en
ese centro bueno querido 76 con 31%
las matemáticas es verdad que no tienen
por qué servir para nada es verdad que
son un edificio precioso un edificio
lógico probablemente uno de los mayores
esfuerzos colectivos que el ser humano
ha hecho a lo largo de la historia pero
también es verdad que allá donde los
científicos donde los técnicos andan
buscando teorías matemáticas modelos que
les permitan avanzar ahí están en el
edificio de las matemáticas que lo
permean todo es verdad que tenemos que
ir algo más al fondo vamos a ver qué hay
detrás de las ciencias la ciencia
funciona por intuición por creatividad y
las matemáticas doma en la intuición y
doma en la creatividad
a casi todo el mundo que no lo ha oído
antes les sorprende que si uno cogiera
una hoja de papel de 0,1 milímetros de
grosor esas que utilizamos normalmente
lo suficientemente grande y la pudiera
doblar 50 veces el grosor de ese montón
ocuparía la distancia de la tierra al
sol
tu intuición te dice eso es imposible
echa las cuentas y verás que si para eso
sirve las matemáticas es verdad que la
ciencia toda la ciencia solamente tiene
sentido porque nos hace comprender mejor
el mundo este hermoso en el que estamos
y porque nos hacen nos ayuda a sortear
las trampas del mundo este doloroso en
el que estamos hay ciencias que tocan
esa aplicación con la mano la ciencia
oncológica por ejemplo y hay otras que
las miramos desde lejos con envidia a
veces pero sabiendo que somos su soporte
todas las ciencias básicas son el
soporte de aquéllas y entre ellas las
matemáticas
todo lo que hace la ciencia ser ciencia
es el rigor de la matemática y ese rigor
les viene porque sus resultados son
eternos
seguramente has dicho o se han dicho
alguna vez que un diamante es para
siempre verdad
a depende lo que uno entienda por
siempre un teorema es así que está
siempre
el teorema de pitágoras el teorema de
pitágoras eso es verdad aunque se haya
muerto pitágoras te digo yo aunque se
une al mundo el teorema de pitágoras
seguiría siendo verdad allá donde se
juntó en un par de catetos y una buena
hipotenusa
teorema de pitágoras funcionan a tope a
tope
bueno los matemáticos nos dedicamos a
hacer teoremas verdades eternas
pero no siempre es fácil saber qué es
una verdad eterna un teorema y que es
una mera conjetura hace falta una
demostración por ejemplo imaginaos que
tengo aquí un campo grande enorme
infinito lo quiero cubrir con piezas
iguales sin dejar huecos podría usar
cuadrados verdad podría usar triángulos
círculos no te dejan huequitos
cuál es la mejor pieza que puede usar la
que para cubrir la misma superficie
tiene un volumen un borde más pequeño
para push de alejandría para push en el
año 300 dijo que lo mejor era usar
hexágonos como hacen las abejas pero no
lo demostró el tío dijo es algo nos lo
peta venga sano dámelo no lo demostrado
se quedó en una conjetura fijos algo nos
el mundo como sabéis se dividió entre
papistas y antipapistas hasta que 1700
años después 1700 años después en 1999
tomás gils demostró que para push y las
abejas llevaban razón que lo mejor es
usar hexágonos y eso se convirtió en un
teorema del teorema del panal que va a
ser verdad para siempre siempre jamás
más que cualquier diamante que tengas
pero qué pasa si vamos a tres
dimensiones si quiero llenar el espacio
con piezas iguales sin dejar huecos
puede usar cubos verdad esferas no que
dejan huequitos
cuál es la mejor pieza que puede usar
robots kelvin el de los grados kelvin
eso s dijo que lo mejor era usar un
octaedro truncado
que como todos sabéis
estoy aquí
quien no tiene unos taladros truncado en
casa aunque sea de plástico trae los
trato que vienen visitas todo el mundo
tiene pero que el vino lo demostró se
quedó en una conjetura la conjetura de
kelvin
el mundo como sabéis
se dividió entre kevin ista así antich
el ministro
hasta que siento y pico años después
ciento y pico años después alguien
encontró una estructura mejor
weir eifelland way day phelan
encontraron esta cosita de aquí
esta estructura a la que pusieron el
imaginativo nombre de estructura de
guayre ife la cndh
parece una cosa rara pero no es tan rara
también está presente en la naturaleza
es muy muy curioso que esta estructura
por sus propiedades geométricas se
utilizó para construir el edificio de la
natación en los juegos olímpicos de
pekín
a ya michael phelps ganó ocho medallas
de oro se convirtió en el mejor nadador
de todos los tiempos pero de todos los
tiempos hasta que salga otro mejor no
como le pasa a la estructura de weir y
phelan es la mejor hasta que salga otra
mejor pero cuidado
porque esta sí que tiene la oportunidad
de que aunque pasen ciento y pico años
aunque sea dentro de 1700 años alguien
demuestre que esta es la mejor pieza
posible y entonces será un teorema una
verdad para siempre siempre jamás
más que cualquier diamante
así que bueno si queréis decirle a
alguien
que le queréis para siempre
te podés regalar diamante pero si le
queréis decir que le queréis siempre
siempre regalarle un teorema
es así
cierto lo tendréis que demostrar que
vuestro amor no se quede en conjetura